Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take a look at the course outline,
and look at the use cases on why or how beneficial layered materials can be. So let's get started.
So first up, we'll talk about use cases, what it takes to use it and why it is beneficial.
Then we'll look at the old way. And then we'll look at the new way. And then we'll also
look at the material designer, which is the newest kid on the block, and how to actually
make a layered material. From there, we'll look at material parameter collections,
we'll look at what is an MPC and setting it up. Then we'll take a look at substance materials,
parallax control, and look at a deep dive in some more complicated materials
when it comes to working with these systems. Alright, so let's get started. So layered
materials. So the use of layered materials are used in Unreal to combine elements that can
be edited. It's used to keep executions clean and prevents a noodle fest. And you'll see an
example of that in just a second. It can be used to create example snow on rock or moss
on wood. What we'll be doing is moss on wood. And we'll look at a snow on rock,
a more complicated sample that I created for Disney, that you can see how things work.
Three ways that this can be accomplished, as mentioned before,
one the old way, we can use multiple, make materials, attributes, and material functions,
and combine them into a system that allows us to layer our textures. And I should say,
it takes the element of each material. So think of it as a PBR layered material,
the new way using layered materials, or the blend material system that actually makes it so
it's a little bit cleaner, and a bit easier to use, although you do need to understand the
systems. So it is kind of step heavy, but I'll walk you through it. And last but not least,
is the material designer way, which is probably one of the more faster ways to get up and
running. And I'll show you how that works. Also, the benefits of it, you can see here,
on these two images, you'll see one when you're using them, that the lines that are
connected between each node are pretty clean. But if you didn't use them, such as you didn't
use that material function with the make attributes, you would have a noodle fest,
and it would be quite messy. Even though you might use named reroute directed nodes,
you still will run into some issues with the organization of things. In the next video,
we're going to dive right in and build some of our own, and I'll show you how it works. Thanks again.